se refugian donde pueden cavando
trincheras para mantener sus posiciones
descansando bajo la protección de las
copas de los árboles estos soldados
ucranianos establecieron su campamento
cerca de la línea del frente en el
donbass el bombardeo aquí y en la región
continua ucrania acusa a rusia de atacar
a civiles e infraestructuras en las
regiones de dónetsk y la oms algo que
moscú niega a estos soldados ucranianos
acaban de tener que retirarse de ruiz a
poco más de 10 kilómetros al norte de
donde están los combates más intensos en
severo donges colors es una tragedia que
nos hayamos retirado nunca deberíamos
haber hecho eso lo que queremos es
atacar lo mismo
era imposible defenderse a todos como
tuvimos que retirarnos de la artillería
rusa lo destruyó todos
todo fue arrasado no había lugar para
esconderse en
las situaciones de severodonezk y sus
alrededores cambia constantemente
después de afirmar que había recapturado
alrededor de la mitad de la ciudad el
gobierno ucraniano dijo que sus
posiciones la batalla casi por casi
habían empeorado
tenemos una situación difícil en el este
que ustedes conocen la situación en
severodonezk y la estamos manteniendo
nos superan el número son más poderosos
pero sin embargo creo que tenemos todas
las posibilidades de luchar en este eje
renovando la petición de más potencia de
fuego seres que ha prometido no rendirse
en severodonezk la mayor ciudad de la
región que aún no está bajo control ruso